♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est l'histoire
improbable d'un dentiste
devenu révolutionnaire.
À première vue, Hamed Esmaeilion
mène une vie ordin
- OK. So, wegogogo
for the crowns.
de Toronto, les patients
se succèdent devant un médecin
attentif et méticuleux.
Mais Hamed est beaucoup plus
qu'un simple dentiste.
Sa vie a basculé le 8 janvier
a été abattu par l'Iran peu
après son décollage de Téhéran.
Les 176 passagers sont morts,
y compris la femme l l l l l l .
- They should be
accountable for th
- Il nous reçoit au deuxième
étage de sa clinique. Il y a
trois ans, clllllllllllllllllll.
"Il y avait un tapis de jeu et
des poupées", se souvient-il.
Depuis l'accident d'avion,
cette pièce est devenue
son quartier général.
des boîtes de paperasse : autant
de signes de son interminable
quête pour obtenir justice.
(slogan en iranien)
Depuis amamamamamamamamamamaman
a pris une nouvelle tournure :
le dststste a joint sa voix
à celle de milliers d'Iraniens
pour demander la chute de
"Quand ils ont tué Mahsa Amini,
toute cette douleur nous est
revenue", explique Hamed.
La mort de la jeune Iranienne
a propulsé le pays dans
qui ne s'essouffle pas.
Une lutte identique
à celle que mène Hamed
depuis presque trois ans.
- (foule): Mahsa Amini!
- Incapable de rester les bras
croisés, Hamed et l'association
décident d'organiser
une première série de
manifestations au Canada.
Leur appel est entendu
partout dans le monde.
le dentiste se retrouve
à coordonner des fefefestations
dans plus de 150 villes.
Le mois dernier, il se rend
à Blin lin lin et prend la paroe
devant 80 000 personnes venues
soutenir les opposants iranienst
de contestation et parvient
à unifier une opposition
jusque-là divisée.
Une pression énorme
pour un père endeuillé
qui se voit surtout comme
une personne ordinaire.
qu'il était spécial",
se souvient le documentarist
Babak Payami, qui a produit
un film sur Hamed.
- What about the truth?nenenenee
iranienne, n'a pas été surpris
oioioir le dentiste devenir
un symbole du mouvement
de contestation.
- They t t to accuse us...
- Mais l'activisme d'Hamed
a un prix. Sur les réseaux
par le régime iranien, à un tel
point qu'il s'inquiète
pour sa sécurité.
Hamed promet toutefois de
continuer la lutte pour
joint leurs voix à celles
rororororororororororororororore
continuer la lutte pour sa femme
etfififille, qui auraient
joint leurs voix à celles
des manifestantes iraniennes
♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪
♪ ♪ ♪Ahmed écoute des chants
révolutionnaires pour
se donner du courage.
Un homme qui a perdu
ce qu'il avait de plus cher
son deuil sans avoir obtenu
justice, lui qui continue
de s'accrocher au rêve
d'un Iran libr